there are those villains whose very
themed shoes make your blood run cold
like Ganondorf who still gets the fear
out of me like he did when I was 7 then
there's the evil brilliance of men like
Andrew Ryan and the disembodied squashy
smash eNOS of lost hand but what about
those gaming villains who are just
downright batshit crazy
let's take the first glimpse we caught a
far cry 4 evil sob at e3 for instance
the game's latest trailer unveiled the
mad tyrant pagan min who's a mix of
deadly charming and completely and
utterly unhinged the dirt is appointed
himself king of the land has a temper
shorter than the memory of a goldfish
and he's fond of magenta suits if that's
not a true madman I don't know what is
well we'll have to wait until November
to see pagan mins madness here are five
of my favorite delightfully insane
villains from gaming first up is what I
like to call a classic crazy monkey
Islands green glowy hat favoring dread
pirate lechuck lechuck is your classic
antagonist intelligent and incredibly
ruthless although he does also come with
Bowser levels of obsession and
unrequited love he spends an awful lot
of time kidnapping and trying to make a
go of it with Elaine love interest of
the series protagonist Guybrush
Threepwood the Chuck typically finds
himself on the losing end by the
conclusion of Monkey Island games but he
does have a tendency to pop back up
again as a ghost zombie demon or what
have you the guy has a serious weakness
for voodoo and although his brazen
attitude and unbridled bad guy
confidence usually lands him with a
sword through his chest he's definitely
one of the craziest and coolest villains
in gaming
never has a video game villain had an
entrance quite as terrifying as Silent
Hill truth Pyramid Head well you could
call the Chuck lovable crazy this
creature with a steel prism encasing his
face it's more like murderous downright
insane holy should stay away from me
crazy the first time he appears is
behind a gate where he makes no attempts
to attack the protagonist James
Sunderland the second is summed up into
an encounter where James sees Pyramid
Head potentially having sex with but
definitely also killing two manikin
creatures Pyramid Head exemplifies Tara
madness and the ultimate villain in this
survival horror game and the wider genre
he kills without remorse and is
extremely tough Pyramid Head is thought
to be a manifestation of James's psyche
representing a judge and executioner
while making James face his guilt and
you know he's completely barbaric and
savage so there's your number for
getting off the horror train to horrible
he is a slightly more charismatic
villain who also happens to be on the
wrong side of crazy
let's talk handsome jack the main
antagonist of Borderlands 2 is a
self-appointed dictator as they all tend
to be and is a little quick to brutally
murder anybody who says anything he
doesn't like he's also quite the
manipulator having effectively gained
control over Pandora using any resource
at his disposal including his own
daughter on top of that he's a big fan
of the Wicked Witch of the West crystal
ball style surveillance of the vault
hunters where he uses the echo nest to
throw down towards and threats to them
wherever he sees fit and he does see fit
like a lot of the time
we may not know all that much about far
cry 4 suit clad antagonist just yet but
we do know an awful lot about the
particular madness that personifies far
cry 3's vas vast Montenegro is just
about as insane as they come as the game
itself explains he's violent
unpredictable and extremely dangerous he
captures the game's protagonist Jason
with plans to ransom off him and his
brother to their parents for cold hard
cash his rap sheet amounts to murder
torture and a series of disturbingly
unhinged monologues that's you're really
better off hearing for yourself and
topping my personal list is an
antagonist from a puzzle platformer who
is absolutely the craziest baddie in
gaming genetic life-form and disk
operating system or GLaDOS for short
GLaDOS is an AI who was once built to
lead testers through the different
chambers in Portal that didn't turn out
so well given she opted to kill off all
the scientists in the Aperture Science
facility with a neurotoxin and then set
out to lead shell portals protagonist to
her death she's a vicious and
manipulative Lee clever villain
generally very capable of anticipating
shell's action she's also kind of a
[ __ ] with a cruel sense of humor as she
often passively aggressively insults
Chell about being fat or useless with
very funny and sadistic one-liners for
me GLaDOS is the perfect insane villain
in gaming and although she meets her
albeit temporary end in portal 1 at
least she gets this thing about it so
unfortunately I only have the time and
space to give you five of my favorite
picks but be sure to let me know who
tops your list and if you agree or
disagree with mine last week I told you
guys about some Xbox one games that I
reckon were worth picking up the console
for after I did an episode about the ps4
here's what you guys thought about
whether or not we should go out and pick
up new generation consoles Jack saw one
two three wasn't so impressed with the
2-u generation lineups as they currently
stand saying none yet leave it until
September October time this
yeah same with ps4 in terms of what will
pump up Xbox one sales Jamie McPherson
21 reckon halo 5 is probably already
done more and we'll continue to do more
to drive sales of X ones than any other
single game feature or function and it's
still a year and a half away from
release and then a lot of you who came
for peggle so consider your voices heard
I'm sure the peggle gods are smiling
down and willing that damn ball bearing
into your pocket as we speak as always
drop me your excellent thoughts and
feelings in that comment box below and I
will endeavor to continue to read all of
them I'll be back next week with a brand
new topic about something else so I'll
see you then